michael mccann legal analyst from Sports
Illustrated si.com how are you Michael
I'm doing well rich double your so I'm
doing fine let's start with what
happened yesterday with Ezekiel Elliott
explain to everybody what is happening
on the legal front right now in in
real-time at 12:30 p.m. Eastern what do
you have for me here
sure so right now judge Mazon a Texas
federal judge is reviewing whether or
not to grant a temporary restraining
order for Elliott judgments clerk's
office has said that we'll get a
decision by Friday if it's granted that
would restrain the NFL from imposing the
sixth game suspension for a limited
period of time probably about two weeks
then there would be an additional
hearing to see if it can be extended and
if he declines to invoke the temporary
restraining order that would be a huge
defeat for Elliott it would be hard for
him to come back from that okay and so
what is what would be the legal standing
that the players is is it the Players
Association that is in front of this
judge or is it Ezekiel Elliot's personal
lawyers the Cowboys who's actually
leading this case Jeffrey Kessler yeah
so Kessler is involved his firm Winston
stron is involved it's really both like
in Tom Brady case where the lawyers
where the player has his own legal team
as well as lawyers from the Players
Association they sort of collaborate and
Kessler I imagine is the quarterback if
you will of this particular case okay
and so what are the what's the legal
standing that their proffer until judge
to say this is why they should rule in
Ezekiel Elliot's favor so the lawyers
for Elliot are basically saying look
unless you grant a temporary restraining
order he's gonna suffer irreparable harm
and that harm is he's going to be
disassociated from his team his team is
going to suffer he's not going to be
able to accumulate statistics and other
things that will advance his career
they're also arguing that it's essential
that he continue to play because they
believe they have a high likelihood of
success but that judgment will
ultimately vacate what what has now
become Harold Henderson zarbor
creation award against Elliot so they
have to show it's kind of a hard burden
they have to show for different prongs
and two of them I just described and
very basically they have to they have to
convince the judge that he's likely
going to rule in favor of Elliot down
the line and that's that's gonna it's a
challenging argument to make okay
Michael McCann of Sports Illustrated
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
then let's rewind this a little bit then
in the fact that Ezekiel le can play
this week it is very confusing to a lot
of people how a suspension can get
upheld and then the NFL agrees to the
fact that he gets to play in week one
why would the NFL do that well the NFL
has issued a statement that that
basically says because the decision of
Harold Henderson wasn't made before
Elliot went to court yesterday it's
essential for fairness that Elliot not
be suspended for this first week's games
it's not it's certainly not required I
think with the end I think what's going
on here is the NFL's mindful of
appearance and mindful of the fact that
they want to seem fair and reasonable
right as judgment is deciding whether or
not to rule in favor of Elliot or the
NFL I think timing matters here if this
case wasn't in court I don't know if the
NFL would be so generous I think frankly
that the NFL is thinking about impact on
the judge and they're also thinking
about other judges could get involved in
this litigation the NFL is trying to
move it to New York even if it stays in
Texas there could be appellate judges so
the NFL is certainly looking at the
optics of what they do in terms of how
judges are reacting to it before we get
to the New York of it all so you're
saying that if if Harold Henderson had
made his ruling before that hearing
started the NFL might not have offered
Ezekiel Elliott the the week one helmet
possibly because the argument would be
that Elliott wouldn't have been
prejudiced in that hearing because he
didn't know what Henderson was gonna do
if he knew then there would have been
less harm on Elliott going into that
well why wouldn't the New York Giants be
hopping mad right now Michael and the
fact that not only is Ezekiel Elliott
gonna suit up against them but the
league says to a judge it's too late in
the week to just sit here and tell him
he can't play week one when Odell
Beckham
was told on a Wednesday once upon a time
he couldn't play in a game yeah it's
hard to reconcile those two things and I
think the Giants would have a valid
argument in terms of logic the NFL would
probably respond saying this is a little
bit different because it's now in the
legal system and secondarily it's the
league's discretion the league doesn't
really have to be consistent by rule it
would be better if they were but they're
not obligated to so why won't this just
wind up in the same way that wound up
with Tom Brady Michael and the fact that
the Players Association can tell as many
judges as it wants that what the league
did was arbitrary it's not fair that the
the league is just red rubber stamping a
decision that they decided to come up
with because they want to look tough on
domestic violence and then it's the
judge just reads the fine print of the
collective bargaining room and says Lika
do what it wants because you signed the
CBA why won't it wind up that way it
probably will that's the most likely
outcome if we go by the Brady decision
if we go by the Adrian Peterson decision
ultimately the judges looked at the
contract and said what you just said
rich which is the fact is the NFL can
more or less do what it wants with
player conduct it doesn't have to be
consistent it doesn't have to share
investigative notes it doesn't have to
have witnesses testify there's nothing
in article 46 of the CBA
that mandates any of those things
happening and the argument the NFL would
say in court at least is if it's so
important to the players and their union
why didn't they negotiate for those
things now other judges it's worth
noting I've looked at this differently
remember two of the judges that Brady
had ruled in his favor judge Berman
right right judge Berman that's exactly
right
in chief judge Katz no to the Second
Circuit ruled in his favor now they
weren't in the majority but they say
wait a second you can't just say if it's
not in the agreement it doesn't exist
there are certain basic elements of
fairness we don't know what judgments
gonna say maybe he's in that school
maybe he's in the other we'll find out
okay so why New York why is the league
filing in new york michael mccann
there's no better jurisdiction for the
NFL than New York because of Tom Brady
because they beat Tom Brady that's now
binding precedent in New York if this
case winds up in New York I don't I
don't see a pathway for Elliott to win
because the judge is going to be
obligated even a sympathetic judge is
going to be
obligated and say the Tom Brady decision
makes it clear unless there are
procedural safeguards actually stated in
article 46 they don't exist
okay so handicap it for me I guess to
wrap it all up Michael handicap this
what what do you think is gonna happen I
I think most likely by the end Elliott
loses but it's hard to read what
judgments gonna do clearly during the
hearing based on the reporting he was
troubled by what happened in the NFL's
investigation of Elliott I don't think
it's beyond the realm of possibility
that he could issue a restraining order
but I don't think at the end Elliott
will prevail just because article 46 is
so disadvantageous for players even if
Elliott gets another couple weeks
without a suspension I think ultimately
he'll service so you're saying most
likely scenario he misses weeks four
through ten so what you're saying that
or or two through eight I mean I think
that if he gets any win it's probably
gonna be at this initial threshold
because the judge could say I have some
concerns I need to take more time to
evaluate this let's basically put things
on hold for a couple weeks with a
restraining order but I don't think
that's the likely outcome rash I think
the likely outcome is that the judge
probably denies the temporary
restraining order but but I don't want
to say that with conviction because
ultimately it's really up to the judge
and he has the discretion and then what
do you think Jerry Jones does about this
do you think that he's gonna cuz I know
if you remember Bob Kraft had a moment
where he thought maybe he should
continue to fight Tom Brady and perhaps
sue the league and thought differently
but Jerry with all honesty he's got his
bust in his jacket already in Canton I'm
wondering what you think Jerry Jones
remedies might be you know the truth is
rich the the law is stacked against
owners suing the league the fact is
owners agree to the commissioner having
final authority on player discipline and
also on team discipline I don't see a
valid or realistic pathway for Jerry
Jones to go to court trying to take on
the NFL I realized he sued the NFL
before back in the 90s you know that was
over a totally different thing that was
really about intellectual property who
has the right to decide exclusive
licensing deal that has nothing to do
with this this is about player conduct
if Jones goes to
I don't think he will but if he does I
don't think it would go anywhere okay do
you have any two cents and what happen
with the Red Sox and Yankees Michael
before I let you go anyway we know
there's a long history of this type of
in baseball espionage if you will using
telescopes binoculars cameras this is
sort of the latest innovation of it
using an Apple phone I don't know if
it's any worse than what's happened in
the past it's interesting that teams
haven't been punished before that
doesn't mean the Red Sox shouldn't be
punished but certainly it's a relevant
fact that this has occurred with some
history without any kind of discipline
but it looks like this time Rob Manfred
maybe wants to send the message and you
might make an example out of the rest
and is there any precedents for the
Commissioner based you can tell and
rules and any any anything in the in the
rulebook that he can lean on for in the
past about what he would do he can lean
on the best interest of the game clause
that's always the catch-all Clause and
the commissioner has to say look it's
against the best interest of baseball to
have what amounts to cheating now the
Red Sox would say well why have you not
use why have you neither you nor any
other commissioner used it over a
hundred years and that's a fair point
but the Commissioner could decide that
this is a this is an opportunity to
basically create new law if you will and
make an example of the Red Sox and I do
have to before I let you go you still
you still have that class in deflategate
you know I have that class on
deflategate but in fact enrollment is up
this fall what do you mean what do you
mean enrollments up last year I mean I
was thinking deflate people are gonna
get sick of deflate gate they can't get
enough of its okay so then as I asked
him the poll question Brocklin we have
to ask a professor at the University of
New Hampshire School of Law was teaching
a class on deflategate the poll question
before you let him go sure Michael
what's the worst Boston sports scandal
Spygate deflategate watch gate none of
the above what he got for me well I
think my game might be the worst because
we know that the team was at fault and
with deflategate there's a lot of
evidence which suggests the Patriots if
they did it there's conflicting evidence
certainly there's not no there's no
neutral scientists that we know of that
a support of the NFL and there are a
whole bunch that have said the NFL is
wrong
guess with watch gate it kind of has a
frivolous quality to it so I don't want
to make it number one particularly
because other teams have done that so I
think spy gate to me is the worst one
because it was an infraction and the
Patriots acknowledged they made a
mistake that to me
I feel best about that one because we
know it actually occurred thank you
Michael
always enjoy our chats thank you much
Michael McCann at McCann sports law the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy